belarus continues to face international
pressure over its crackdown on
journalists
among them dw reporter alexander burakov
he was just released after serving a
20-day sentence during which he says
he was tortured we are in close
communication with him and he told us he
is doing fine
but does need time to recover before
speaking publicly
we'll talk to human rights watch about
his case in a moment but first
here's a look at the dangerous situation
facing journalists
in the autocratic country
belarusian journalist alexander burkhoff
was covering the trial of an opposition
politician in may
he was arrested and charged with joining
an illegal demonstration
is among the dozens of reporters who
faced prosecution by the belarusian
regime
in recent months exile journalists can
only watch from across the border
in fear what is happening in belarus is
terrible
considering the pressure on independent
media and the number of journalists that
are put behind
bars it's really shocking
belarusian journalists are increasingly
up against the wall
in may police raided the offices of news
outlet tutbai
and detained staff it's not the first
time it was targeted
one of its journalists had already been
sentenced to six months in jail
and last year toothbay was stripped of
its media license
after releasing footage of protests and
arrests
[Music]
another critical news outlet under
pressure is nester
it's been labelled an extremist
organization by belarusian authorities
neshita's co-founder raman pratasevich
had been reporting from abroad
until he was seized from a commercial
aircraft that was forced to land
in minsk he's been charged with inciting
some of the mass demonstrations
that have rocked belarus since august
last year
challenging the outcome of disputed
presidential elections
since then almost 500 reporters have
been arrested
according to the belarusian journalists
association
more than 20 remain behind bars
many of those who have been released say
they suffered physical
and mental abuse like dw's alexander
burakov
punishment for reporting on a brutal
regime
we can speak now to hugh williamson he's
the director of europe and central asia
at human rights watch here in
berlin hugh thank you for joining us now
after
his release our reporter alexander
budakov said the detention facility he
was being held in was like
a military prison and he also said that
he'd been subjected to torture and
inhumane treatment
do those accusations surprise you
unfortunately not no they don't surprise
me
human rights watchers documented a
number of similar cases in recent
uh weeks and months in fact with
documented cases where
um journalists were brutally beaten
while in detention
they were denied medical assistance
held in extremely poor conditions just
like your colleague reported
their equipment was uh confiscated and
destroyed
we've also documented cases where
journalists who are in detention have
been
threatened that they their children will
be taken away when they are released and
taken into um
taken away from them and protected and
looked after by the state so to speak so
different forms of physical mental uh
harassment which
in our view does often amount to torture
yeah so unfortunately this is not a
surprising development
and this is not a small number of cases
hugh we said almost 500 journalists have
been detained since last year so
what impact does that have on the media
landscape and on journalists working in
belarus
indeed i mean first let's remember
belarus has an
established and very strong and
courageous
media community of journalists of media
reporters media organizations has long
had that but they've been under brutal
attacks particularly since august last
year since the presidential
elections let's also remember indeed the
courage of journalists to keep on
working both inside belarus and outside
but to answer your question the
immediate impact is that many
journalists have had to
um either go underground or flee the
country as we know there are many
or a number of good media organizations
which are set up
outside uh belarus now some of them in
um
in baltic countries some of them in
poland
and they're doing extremely good work
under very difficult circumstances
we know that there's been international
condemnation of the situation demands to
free journalists and allow independent
reporting
but does that really have any effect on
president lukashenko
of course we don't really know the
answer to that but i mean my
essence would be it does because you
know he's become increasingly
desperate evidently um the the
the pulling down of the the hijacking of
the plane
um nine days ago that's been widely
reported is a sign
that he's desperate to to reign in
even those journalists who are working
abroad
so continued independent reporting and
continued international support for that
independent reporting is really crucial
to enable
um that to continue in order for the
pressure to continue on lukashenko from
from other eu member states for instance
from germany um
support for independent independent
media is vital as we go forward in this
i mean
it's difficult to see how it's going to
end but certainly um
the continued work on on these issues by
such journalists
is vital hugh williamson from
human rights watch thank you for
speaking with us
don't mention it